[Music]  too much honey oh my gosh is that guy  have a fidget spinner oh that's so lame  yeah you would never catch me with a  fidget spinner I don't get the appeal  neither they're just stupid toys what's  the point are they supposed to help you  focus cuz I think they're crazy  distracting it's such a dumb trend I  just think they're getting in the way of  everything I'm so sick of them if I have  to see another video about a fidget  spinner I'm gonna lose grown adults  trying so hard to be relatable our  fidget spinner supposed to help you  concentrate because it's definitely not  working not even that relax digit  spinners need to end to fidget spinners  [Music]